welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live i love podcast
lord the gaming.net more incognito here
and who are these two fine gentlemen in
the realm today
i'm andrew tracy one of the two tracy
brothers
and i'm cory tracy the other tracy
brother
shout out to the tracy bunch and what is
this what's the studio you guys have and
what is this game that we're going to
talk about so we're tracy brothers we're
an indie studio that focuses on strategy
rpg and tactics games for the last 10
years this is our eighth game uh born
from a kickstarter our latest
kickstarter uh
largest kickstarter cyberknights
flashpoint it's a tactical heist rpg a
mix of uh turn-based combat
stealth
and hacking oh this is all that we we're
in the realm we love our turn-based
games we love our x-com style game and
now you're mixing stealth and sorry for
that you got to tell us more about this
game so break it down shot the lord
attic on the gameplay right now so we
have what's going on here just give us
some basic premise gameplay loop i see i
got our attack points and i see some
sneaking stuff going on let's just give
it an overview of what's going on right
now so we're in the middle of a mission
where things have gone wrong
our main man hemlock is in prison in
this cell over here
and we've got to get him out there's a
guard in our way and once we can get him
out we can start making our way back to
the exit where we know our friend rhino
is waiting
so we're going to sneak around get an
advantageous position on the guard get
hemlock out of that cell and figure out
a plan to get through the rest of this
corporate facility so now i'm assuming
in this this kind of phase this is
almost like a stealth phase we're not
detected yet kind of a deal that's
correct okay so what i'm seeing right
now looking like our
camera light right now it's kind of
patrolling in a patrol phone now my
question is
in this stealth mode if you take down
enemies in this mode is there a
situation where we can remain in trouble
absolutely
awesome yeah so
there's two kinds of ai there's the
guard each ai each guard has an
artificial intelligence and a knowledge
and then the overall security system
gets information from the cameras and
the guards on the radio but only at the
end of the turn so you can take out a
guard and if nobody sees you nobody's
the wise i see that's what i like i i
like the ai to do that i can maintain a
stealth phase and i think that's
important it's kind of rare honestly a
lot of turn-based games usually once the
engagement happens at that point
yeah and we've worked on not only that
but even when you make some mistakes
it's pretty important to be able to get
the cloak back up so if you can hide
some bodies disintegrate some bodies
shut down some security the terminal and
hack something you can quiet things back
down again so you can get going we got
to stop in place you said hide the
bodies we disintegrate
yeah so we're inspired by games like
metal gear solid that have those sort of
pick up and hide the bodies mechanics so
he's dropped a guard here you can see
killed the first guard in the room there
are any other guards around so right now
that's not a big deal but in a couple of
turns somebody's gonna say where did bob
go yeah and they're gonna start looking
for him so you either need to make sure
they don't find him
move quick enough that you're out of the
zone that it doesn't matter or find
another way to keep the things rolling
actually this is pretty awesome now as
far as we're saying right now eddie's
controlling one guy who's a main
character
do you have the ability to gain more
people in your party or is it primarily
the single player turn based up it is a
single player game but it's a squad game
so he is about to if things go well
release the second character who is the
leader and the kind of super tactician
behind the group he's got a quantum
computer
embedded in his spine and the ability to
manipulate the initiative track
and boost your squad members in ways
that nobody else can so you can get up
to most missions are averaging three or
four characters at a time but it can go
up to six depending on the big boss and
long extended missions now when you gain
these characters these are forever in
your party but just for the mission in
itself because like free people you've
helped people out as an rpg the focus is
on
you building out your squad both for
character builds so there's a
multi-classic system you have a sizable
skill tree that you can design your
exact powers from but then all the
characters get woven into the rpg story
so you're making choices
does these choices impact anything in
this demo
the future impacts are only about
dialogue lines you have to be honest but
throughout the game it's an rpg so
absolutely there's overarching stories
there's binary choices you have to make
there's pathing there's different
endings
and
about half of the stories originate from
inside your squad okay so the world
wants stuff from you but you have a
group of misfits and malcontents and
mercenaries on your hands
they need things they want things they
have family trouble they've got they
need help
so uh there's a lot yeah we're trying to
bring them alive by bringing them into
the story so they're not just warriors
you're taking on the mission but in a
lot of cases they're the reason you're
on the mission gotcha you're trying to
steal this medication to help echo's kid
brother who's real sick
and if you don't take this mission
echo's gonna go try and steal it herself
and she'll be gone for two weeks and you
need that
waiting around yeah so you've got to
make that choice like who am i willing
to sacrifice who am i willing to put it
on the line for i love it i love the
dynamic nature of it the emerging
question is gamepl on like really
stressing rpg level mechanics now is
there like another top layer is there a
skill tree are we going that rough
absolutely
yeah there's a big in the flyer we can
show you there's every class has a
sizable skill tree to work your way
through you pick mechanics and then you
pick boosts on those mechanics so he has
an ability it does something but he can
have five or six more upgrades to it to
make it longer range hit harder last
longer and then on top of it there's an
overarching strategy layer in your safe
house so you've got a
network of that was my next question
smugglers you know
corporate arms dealers cops people that
you're bribing people you're doing
favors for missions for so one of the
big things that we've based this off is
uh table tap rbgs okay and that before
you go on a mission like in a in a
heist world if you think of a heist
movie you're never just like oh going on
the heist
so we focus a lot on the legwork in
advance you're going to bribe some
people you're going to find out what
comps on duty that night can i talk to
them can i make sure the reinforcements
are a little slow gotcha and your
getaway
we have a lot of difficulties we love
difficulty as a studio so yes your
characters can go down permanently um
we're pretty gentle in the demo i think
so
as as far as like gameplay mechanics
i noticed that this he's a little bit
more long-range than she is okay could
you convert him to something else or is
they usually go the way they're filming
no you're mixing uh your your class
the weapon choices you have so he can
switch to a short gun shotgun
so he's now much shorter range louder
right so you're then modding your
weapons you can put silencers on weapons
you can put extra barrel attachments
just to clarify yeah this is they might
hear you this is they will here uh this
is just range of uh
oh god oh okay gotcha
the range of the hearing right now it's
not visually displayed shotguns are loud
so most of the people in the level are
going to hear you if you shoot that shot
for a few years yeah yeah absolutely
you can build a lot of different styles
that blue panel is your next uh go-to
awesome
so you have the ability to customize
them in so many ways including since
it's 2231
really cool cyberware
one of the builds in this the options
you can play in the demo has a chameleon
sheath uh cybernetic installed and she
can go completely invisible for a short
amount of time we've got people who can
throw up energy barriers we've got
people who can teleport control
cybernetic dogs
uh rigged drones et cetera
drones and uh and cybernetic cats
we went all the way and we haven't had a
catch yes sir
okay listen i love how you guys are
dogging into this cyberpunk aesthetic
it's an extra it's added that everything
that seems very cool love the art style
and i was going to say from the engine
standpoint what is this is this unity is
it really like what is the background
engine for cyberknife so this is built
in unity
um so this is our first unity game we're
really really excited about the uh about
unity as an engine i think it's bringing
a lot of cool things
like one of the things that we were able
to do that's that i think unity enabled
is we're using real physics for the
grenades nice so it's like it's a
tactical game but we're doing a bunch of
stuff that is very similar to how a
shooter would implement it so there's
grenade deflection and explosion
channeling
and you'll be able to push people around
the three-dimensional
components of the architecture so pull
them out from cover or shove them into a
corner what's your question
i noticed that they said i have security
in my head are they reporting that they
don't say that he's not talking that is
correct and he's just patrolling
so
uh
the security ai which is an overarching
enemy for you
has detected that a guard didn't check
in okay oh after a number of turns so
got it now so he's
going here
yeah they're gonna head that direction
yeah it would be better just to stay
here
so it is a heist it can't be a pitch
battle you actually need to get out of
here so you do need to go up there you
have to cut your way through or sneak
your way past
but the security ai gets a report a
missing body it picks a guard it wants
to go the rest of them are currently it
looks like it's that guy yeah um here it
comes the rest of them are still doing
their regular patrol thing until they
either hear something get shot or get an
order from the security ai the ai is
sort of uh it's on a threshold so if one
guard's missing it's like okay bob
hasn't checked in will you go check and
see what he's doing
now if seven guards go missing in that
back room it's gonna send everybody can
find right at that point it's called red
yep i got you everybody call it the fact
that you've got that type of system
embedded in a turn-based game involved
is actually really cool leaning into
stealth i kind of rarely see that i feel
in the turn-based jar and it's really
cool from a development standpoint how
long have this has uh
summer nights been in development so we
were here in pax east 2020 with our
kickstarter we were in the kickstarter
room we were currently kick-starting
uh so
two years old and we'll be out at the
hopefully the end of this year awesome
which lists us on steam because we're
coming to steam and we'll pour the
consoles next year oh we like that we
got to get the wishlist profit on that
what's up that's interesting the
television
overwatch threat yeah so this dude has
got your pin if you try to shoot at him
or move he's going to shoot you is it
like a hundred percent guarantee uh he
has his regular uh like if you scoot
along your best bets probably move one
ap that way because you're behind pretty
good cover hard cover
um he'll fire at you
so and that cancels his overwatch so now
you're out from under threat got it this
is pretty cool so again development
hopefully gotta wish this thing so we
could get it out there
now you're looking to go to major
consoles
xbox playstation
switch or right now what what those are
the three those are the ones we like
it's absolutely fantastic a ton of fun
now as far as like lent gameplay hours
what are we looking at long term for
cybernetics we're a small studio we love
making big games uh we're roughly as the
big overarching story campaign if you
just want to play through it once 40
plus hours
yeah we'd like a big game for an rpg
and that's if you really you know it's a
regular play time and we love to look
for ways to make sure it has a procter
story under underneath that will weave a
different story every time you play so
you want to come back and sink more
hours into it try a totally different
tactical build there's a lot of space
for you to to play again and there'll be
a ton of those choices that have real
impacts downstream you know we made some
choices in the demo but you'll be making
serious story altering choices who do
you support nice and maybe the character
you don't support gets deleted from the
game oh wow they're dead so we have
those permanent effects those perfect
choices make the game play a little
really cool this is super promising
loving what i'm hearing and it's two
brothers making the game how's it
making the game how does that work it's
awesome
it's kind of always been this way since
i don't know forever when we were like
drawing uh drawing stuff
our own character sheets who pushes back
and who the most on decisions
i don't know we're both very stubborn
yeah so uh i don't know stubborn about
different things so i think that's one
of the ways we work together is um we
both respect what the other person is
really passionate about
and i think uh we really rely a lot on
our community to help us drive the
direction we really listen as much as we
can to the community and that i think
has been a good guide for us what what
our community is saying so right now we
have a thousand kickstarter backers from
the el who are on our elephant team or
playing the game right now okay so
that's a big part of it we think six to
nine months but we listen to them as to
how long that'll be before we'll do a
release so awesome so we want to get as
much information as possible where can
people go to support cyber nights is it
a discord where can they go to really
help you guys out to get this thing
across the finish line check us out on
twitter cybernightsrpg on twitter or
right now we have a a wishlist page up
on steam so hit us there we're on the
community every day if you post we will
respond
we have a discord tracy brothers
uh verified discord check us out awesome
you heard it here first again cyber
night flashpoint tactical rpg cybernetic
action a lot of depth to it one to look
out for absolute pleasure to have you
guys both in the room very embarrassing
game we look forward to your coming out
again you heard it here first let's have
a nice flight for y'all check it out
[Music]
you